[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
méxico es paso obligado para los
migrantes que buscan llegar a eeuu desde
centroamérica y allí a muchos se les ha
perdido el rastro durante años familias
de migrantes desaparecidos llegan en una
caravana para exigir respuestas sobre el
paradero de sus seres queridos así se
movilizaron este 2022
[Música]
en la cara
este grupo de madres busca a sus hijos
desaparecidos y lo hace en un país que
no es el suyo
[Música]
son familiares de migrantes
centroamericanos a quienes se les perdió
el rastro en su viaje hacia eeuu el
nombre de mi hijo es rafael alberto roll
y una vez más estoy aquí buscando lo
mismo mejor que el tiempo que ha
transcurrido
para mí el tiempo se ha detenido para mí
pues que mi hijo
desde que salió de la casa pues yo
guardo la esperanza de
y la fe de que lo voy a encontrar
los buscan en méxico un país donde se
reportan altísimas cifras de
desaparecidos al menos 98 mil personas
según el último reporte y a las que se
suman los migrantes
[Música]
[Aplausos]
que nos apoyen hacer las búsquedas que
busquen ellos también donde nosotros les
dejamos pistas que nos dan esas piezas
dónde están nuestros familiares que
ellos
en favor de moverse a gustar está a cada
uno de los familiares que están
desaparecidos que son centenares esta
caravana y sus peticiones no son nuevas
durante años los familiares de migrantes
desaparecidos caminan por méxico para
pedir ayuda esperamos que nos pueda
recuperar saltar y sobre todo que
garantice y respeta a la derecha humana
a las personas migrantes en una
situación
o sea se ha visto las políticas
migratorias mal implementada y sobre
todo cuando tiene tintes militarización
no ayuda en nada absolutamente esta
movilización fue creada por el
movimiento migrante mesoamericano desde
2004 para llamar la atención de las
autoridades y exigir acción en la
búsqueda a los migrantes desaparecidos
desde hace 15 años el servicio jesuita a
migrantes actualiza sobre los
extranjeros que emigraron y
desaparecieron en mexico donde están se
lo preguntamos a alberto baltasar cruz
coordinador de incidencia de la
fundación
lo que encontramos en el informe también
con base en este programa de las
personas que nosotros localizamos
alrededor de 75% se encontraban en
estaciones migratorias es decir eran
personas que venían realizando o
ingresando al país y durante su tránsito
fueron detenidas por las autoridades en
específico por el instituto nacional de
inmigración y posteriormente llevadas a
estaciones migratorias o estancias
provisionales que hacer los lugares
donde las autoridades pues llevan a las
personas migrantes en lo que se decide
qué es lo que se va a hacer con ellos y
las desapariciones de personas migrantes
pues tienen el lugar por una cantidad de
factores por ejemplo en el sur de eeuu
las desapariciones tienen que ver con
personas que se quedan en el desierto
por porque se instalaron porque se
deshidrataron porque sufrieron alguna
fractura y posteriormente nadie sabe a
ciencia cierta en qué punto quedaron y
pues permanecen como desaparecidas y
tenemos conocimiento de otras personas
que por ejemplo se caen del tren en el
caso de que estén viajando encima de él
y por alguna por algún motivo se
resbalan o se avientan o son alentadas
por alguna algún grupo del crimen
organizado de la delincuencia común y
pues quedan a lo largo de las vías del
tren sin saber también su paradero y
tenemos obviamente aquellas
desapariciones pues que van más
vinculadas con el actual del crimen
organizado donde las desapariciones pues
se vinculan por ejemplo con crímenes
como lo que es el secuestro y la
desaparición el trabajo forzado el
servicio jesuita a migrantes detalla que
no hay claridad en los datos de
migrantes desaparecidos y por eso aunque
estén bajo custodia de las autoridades
se desconoce su paradero
si bien ahora hay hay ciertas
facilidades para reportar las
desapariciones de lugares de origen a
través del mecanismo de atención en el
extranjero pues aún hacen falta por
ejemplo mecanismos para a través de los
cuales poder hacer un seguimiento de sus
casos en el caso de algunas de las
personas que hemos atendido familiares
nos dicen que al momento que han
interpuesto estos reportes en este
estado por este medio y sin embargo no
saben
en qué estado va su caso si fue atendido
si fue descartado etcétera es decir no
hay los mecanismos de seguimiento
adecuados para poder saber otra cosa que
hemos mencionado en el informe es acerca
de la necesidad urgente porque como te
mencionaba el 75% de las personas que
localizamos en el programa de búsqueda
estaban en una estación migratoria
entonces las autoridades ya por mandato
deberían contar con un registro de las
personas migrantes que están siendo
detenidas y llevadas a estaciones
migratorias instancias provisionales que
permitiría este registro pues que las
personas desde sus lugares de origen
pudieran meter la información de sus
familiares y saber prácticamente en
tiempo real si están en alguna estación
migratoria y eso obviamente para
organizaciones que hacemos búsqueda o
que colaboramos en las cuestiones de
búsqueda pues nos evitaría tener que
perder tiempo buscando en estos espacios
y en su caso si no están ahí pues
dedicarlo a otro a la búsqueda en otros
espacios en donde las personas todos
pudieran estar
desde 2007 y hasta 2021 el 14 por ciento
de los migrantes desaparecidos y luego
localizados serán niños niñas y
adolescentes estos según los reportes
del servicio jesuita a migrantes
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]